Transcriber: Rasha Nasser
المدقّق: Bashar Al-Thawabta
(تصفيق)
اهلًا بالجميع!
أنا اسمي لين.
انا هنا لأتحدث عن امرًا يجعلني سعيدة حقًا.
ألعابي!
إنهم مثل اعز اصدقائي.
و أريد ان اخبركم لماذا هم ثمينين جدًا
بالنسبة لي
هذه دميتي المفضله.
وحيدة القرن البراقه.
وهي وحيدة قرن رقيقه ومحبوبه.
أحب معانقتها لأنها تشعرني بالدفء والأمان.
خصوصًا، حينما يحين موعد النوم.
وحيدة القرن البراقه تساعدني في الاسترخاء
والنوم العميق
انا..
أتعلمون ما الشيّق بالألعاب؟ إنهم
قادرين على ان يأخذوك الى مغامرات مذهله!
حينما ألعب مع ألعابي، مثل الدمى،
أستطيع ان اتخيل جميع انواع الأمور الممتعه
التي استطيع فعلها في المستقبل.
حينما ألعب مع ألعابي
كالدمى خاصتي، أستطيع ان اتخيل
جميع انواع الاشياء الممتعه
التي استطيع
التي استطيع فعلها
أستطيع ان اذهب الى الفضاء الخارجي
أو اغوص في اعماق المحيط
ان اقوم بالتخيل اني في رحلةٍ
بينما انا جالسةً في غرفتي.
الألعاب ليست فقط مصنوعه لكي تلعبها وحيدًا
إنها ايضًا تساعدني بصنع صداقات جديده
عندما احضر العابي للمدرسة،
أو اذهب بها الى منزل صديقتي
نقوم باللعب معًا ونحظى بالكثير
من الوقت الممتع
ونتبادل الأدوار ونتشارك ونتعلم
كيف ان نصبح لطيفين لبعضنا البعض
لطالما كان ذلك يساعدنا في ان نتواصل
وان نبني صداقات
انا أحب الرسم والتلوين
بطباشيري ودفاتر التلوين.
انها طريقة لأعبر بها عن نفسي
وان اظهر ماذا اشعر به في داخلي.
هو مثل امتلاك..
انا استطيع ان اصنع صورًا جميله
صورًا جميله، وهذا ما يجعلني سعيده.
انه مثل امتلاك معرضًا فنيّا خاصًا بي.
احيانًا، تساعدني الألعاب في ان
أحيانًا، تساعدني الألعاب في ان احلم
عن ماذا اريد ان اكون حينما ابلغ رشدي
عندما ألعب، اتظاهر.
استطيع ان اكون دكتوره، معلمه،
أو حتى إطفائيه.
إنه مثل تجريب عدة وظائف.
وتخيل جميع انواع الأمور الممتعه
التي استطيع فعلها في المستقبل.
اصدقائي الاعزاء،
في المرة التاليه التي ستلعب فيها مع ألعابك
تذكر انهم اكثر من كونهم عباره عن اجسام
انهم وسائل سحريه
التي بإمكانها ان تساعدك على التعلم،
والنمو، والإستمتاع.
وتمتع بالعالم المذهل.
اسمح لخيالك بالنمو
وتمتع بالعالم المذهل من الألعاب.
شكرًا لإستماعكم لحديثي.
اتمنى لك يومًا رائعًا
وان تحظى بالكثير من الوقت الممتع
الى اللقاء!
(تصفيق)